hleon Verletzung dorax beidseits links
größer kein atemusch links Amputation
vom nfsam versorgt worden mit chess mit
einer Bandage und mit donik von mir
versorgt mitf Orangen mit einer Infusion
K zur Schmerztherapie
und er hat kein a geht B war der auf der
linken
Seite
wegen der
amputationet
volumengab kein Problem er DRT langsam
langsam ein und kann
nicht ansprechbar starke
schmerzenestellt das
war
wir
von geht mit de
Schmerzen ziemlich
[Musik]
massiv pun von
atmungabil die Atmung
stabilisierenitte Patienten 40
m
GZ bitte auch noch
mer
aufziehen sie kriegen jetzt erst schkel
bitte schauen d
schnell danke Maut sehr
[Musik]
gter bitte noch ein bisschen geben jetzt
auch
[Musik]
noch wir werden eines machen W ihre
brung versorgt ist wenn wir sie den K
tischlaf legen ich sage Ihnen dann wann
das sein wird wi Land Ken Sie jetzt
gleich mal ein bisschen Z Beruhigung wir
sind daher keine
Sorge w sehr gut mach bitte gib ih 5 mg
wieder Z l jetzt kommt ein bisschen ein
berüungsmittel jawoh merken sie schon
etwas ist schon etwas besser mit den
Schmerzen gut so dann schauen wir mal
hier von den propilen her es ist
momentan hier mittelweit ja es geht ein
bisschen zu das geht WG haben sie hier
Schmerzen das weh ja die Augen sind noch
auf
eter mal anschließen bitte genau Andreas
bitte du hängst noch die Infusion an
eine weitere
die hier vollauf reinschü vollauf
lassen ja bitte schön und zwar bitte
aufzi 100 mg ketan 10 mg Milan und 100
mg
roronion sout
steht zugemacht wir brauchen ein
bisschen was
zumatmen so schauen wir
malich ich mal ein bisschen was mal hier
die Maske drauf nicht
erschrecken
geh es geht gut
125 sehr gut ich trotzdem ein bisschen
den Beutel drauf ganz ruhig jetzt
inieren
so wie ist es denn mit der Blutung
untente gen sie kriegen jetzt noch ein
Schläuchlein in den hinein haben sie
eine schwere Verletzung und die Lunge
funktioniert nicht richtig sonst
jamen ganz normal weititte no Andreas
einesäure bitte
schönsä die bitte in die Infusion
[Musik]
machen
jaelverstlichelverstlich ich würde no
diesätzlich K sch
voriten extrem hoch
ja ja
bitte
age ganz ruhig also die stigung ist noch
in
[Musik]
ordnungam
genau bitte
rein genau jetzt
bekommenmen sie ganz ruhig
weiter in dieusion
genau ja dann MS also diegen jetzt noch
enage geht
mit
78 bisschen mehr beatmen gut sonst GI
wir bitte noch einen
wendelturbus die medizinische Versorgung
des österreichischen bundesh im
Einsatzfall gliedet sich in vier
verschiedenen unterschiedlichen rolls
das sind Leistungsgruppen Roll n0 wäre
ESH die erweiter selbst und
Kameradenhilfe die jeder recrut und
jeder Soldat machen kann Roll 1 wäre die
nächste Stufe das wäre dann in der Runde
der des Bataillons in einen Zug sahnzug
der die Patienten stabilisiert Roll 2
sind Krankenhäuser die den Patienten
chirurgisch stabilisieren können und
Roll 4 wäre dann die definitiv
Versorgung Roll 3 dazwischen ist ein
Zwischending zwischen Roll 2 und Roll 4
wo vieles gemacht werden kann aber nicht
die definitiv Versorgung der Patienten
im
Einsatzfall wir fangen jetzt an mit
intion sie haben schon ein paar
Medikamente hier
bekommen gen schon
seh
geben gut also wir wer sie
jetztieren
andreeritte
80 mg bitte
gib
genau m ja genau nicht ja genau
pas drin dann bitte hier 10
m gich geht in den
Schlaf
mus dasium bitte noch 100
m genau spritz ih bitte 8 ml ja von den
Zeeh gibt ih bitte a dann hat er 80 mg
das passt ungefähr zum
Körpergewicht jawohl das müsste ich
eigentlich H 2 Minuten warten aber in
dem Fall glaub ich cren ja okay dann
würde ich den Patienten jetzt
[Musik]
interierenprchen ich das kurz mal auf
die Seite
so
[Musik]
w so bitte den turbus blocken bitte
einoskop und den Patienten Abhören ich
küm mich ums
bebeuteln
jawohl
jawohenten wie ist die
Sauerstoffsättigung bitte wie sind ist
die
Sauerstoffsättigung ja bitte ja dann die
at der Patient ist alsrauma gekommen in
einem instabilen Zustand das heißt weder
der Atmung war gesichert und hat immer
noch relativ stark geblutet und die
Aufgabe hier vom Notfallteam war in
einfach kreiswissig zu stabilisieren die
Blutung zu stoppen und eine
atemsituation herzubringen dass keine
akute Lebensgefahr besteht das heißt er
ist inzwischen die Lunge ist entlastet
worden von dem Blut drinnen und ist
intuert worden und künstlich okay gut
jawoh so hab wir die verungsmaschine
anschließen er wird aufgrund seiner des
Blutverlustes Blutkonserven brauchen und
man wird diesen stumpf natürlich dann
auch decken müssen das heißt dass die
Wunde das nicht mE ein Stumpf ist mit
ein freiligen Knochen und Ende und
Muskulatur sondern das dass der Stumpf
plastisch gedeckt werden kann und dann
wird sicher einige Tage eine intensive
äh betreiung
[Musik]
brachen